hablando de salud llegó el momento de
nuestra sección con más romeros a la mar
ya empezamos entonces esta nueva semana
feliz me une feliz mañana llevamos ya
dos años de esta crisis sanitaria del
cobat 19 parece no sé si poco o mucho
dependientes pero como ya estaría si
estamos saliendo bueno en fin y hace
unos meses empezaron a hablar de la fase
pandémica que esto ya se termine hacia
dónde vamos mal pues buenos días buenos
lunes también realmente se dice rápido
que llevamos dos años pero es muchísimo
tiempo y precisamente por eso creo que
deberíamos de empezar a estar ya bien
familiarizados con unos términos eso es
lo que venimos para explicar hoy también
porque la última palabra de moda un poco
ha sido que vamos a llegar a esta fase
endémica de la crisis sanitaria del cobi
19 pero no sabemos exactamente o
queremos saber exactamente qué implica
eso entonces precisamente para resolver
esas dudas y para saber de qué estamos
hablando estamos con carlos de eduardo
pérez como cada lunes también médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor muy buenos días
gracias por acompañarnos un día más en
este inicio empecemos dando un paso
atrás al principio hace dos años yo
recuerdo ese momento en el que dijimos
que pasábamos de una de una epidemia
perdón a una pandemia cuál es la
diferencia de estos dos términos
hola marc buenos días uno de los
primeros es brote epidémico brote
epidémico en la aparición inusitada de
una enfermedad en una localización
geográfica una epidemia es cuando esa
transmisión se hace en una región
geográfica determinada la pandemia tiene
que cumplir dos requisitos primero que
esa epidemia esté en dos continentes o
más y que ya no hayan casos importados
sino que la propagación y en la clave
sea
autónoma es decir que cada una de las
regiones no importe casos si no sea
capaz de propagar los casos dentro de su
comunidad eso es un brote epidémico una
epidemia restricción geográfica y una
pandemia una pandemia propagación global
doctor muy buenos días feliz y viene ese
también desde nuestro estudio aquí en
france 24 antes se le preguntó qué
significa entrar a una fase endémica del
cob y 19
raúl en leche que pase a una endemia
quiere decir que nos acompaña que su
transmisión es constante
en todas las regiones del mundo pero que
se localiza por ejemplo estacionalmente
o en una región geográfica o en una
población determinada quiere decir que
esta enfermedad y eso va a pasar con el
coronavirus nos va a acompañar por
décadas el hecho de que pase a una fase
endémica no quiere decir que se elimine
simplemente que hace parte de otras
enfermedades que son en este caso
enfermedades respiratorias
precisamente por eso no que otros
ejemplos de enfermedades endémicas
tenemos para quizás ayudar a comprender
mejor de qué estamos hablando cuando
decimos esta palabra
son muchas más por ejemplo la influenza
por ejemplo el vih en la malaria son
enfermedades que empezaron como brotes
epidémicos en regiones epidemias por
ejemplo el caso de la malaria en áfrica
y una extensión global esa fue esa fase
pandémica pero hoy es una endemia porque
la malaria está localizada en todas las
regiones del mundo pero que tengan unas
características geográficas determinadas
la influenza por ejemplo también es una
pandemia pero es un su comportamiento es
endémico porque está en las regiones y
por ejemplo con las estaciones del
invierno o de las lluvias se exacerba el
número de casos eso es una endemia y eso
es una la consecuencia en una pandemia
doctora entonces significa más o menos
que ya no debe preocuparnos por el 19
el hecho de que sea la enfermedad de
erika no quiere que pierda la seguridad
simplemente que su propagación está
contenida en la región pero no querer mí
que sea menos grave y que no vaya a
producir nuevos brotes epidémicos o
puede hacer una nueva variante u otra
pandemia todo lo contrario la pandemia
lo que significa es que tenemos que
adoptar las medidas para poder controlar
los enfermos detectarlos tempranamente y
evitar obviamente la expansión de esta
enfermedad o de sus variantes en otra
región pero es una forma de convivencia
de políticos hemos visto lo que ha
sucedido también por ejemplo con la
variante o micro en que ha llegado a
alarmar de nuevo la comunidad
internacional y varios países es posible
que precisamente por eso la falta de
vacunación global en todo en todos los
continentes haga que se retrase o que
nunca logremos llegar a un lugar
controlado a una fase endémica de esta
crisis de kobe 19
sin duda mientras haya transmisión
mientras sea y día de la enfermedad y
eso si usted en la población no vacunada
pueden aparecer nuevas variantes y uno
de los problemas grandes es que ya el
problema no es que no haya vacuna sino
que la gente no quiere vacunarse
mientras haya casos nuevos siempre va a
verla por la probabilidad de nuevas
cepas de nuevas variantes y eso haría re
emerger este virus por eso el llamado
siempre va a ser a la equidad de las
vacunas a la educación para que todos
nos proponemos y que la obligatoridad
sea acompañada de medidas de educación
que sean realmente eficientes y lleven
el mensaje que la vacunación no es un
acto individual sino es un acto
colectivo de protección así el doctor a
cuidarnos y también a cuidar a las demás
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre todos los lunes en
nuestro espacio de salud de directo
américa gracias mar gracias doctor vamos
ahora a pasar en este segundo invitado
del día
[Música]
costa rica